we want a Europe devoted to peace
building with a foreign policy that also
echoes diverse voices we do not want a
European army but for unity and to
promote our common citizenship we want
all soldiers in Europe to wear a common
symbol on their uniforms a Europe that
provides a common education framework so
that all citizens have lifelong access
to relevant and inclusive education
opportunities including intercultural
exchanges as part of national
curriculums
we want a Europe whose institutions
communicate efficiently with each other
and with external organizations and
where there are no bureaucratic
procedures accountable institutions
should share information with their
citizens such as MEP expenses we want a
Europe that is connected by excellent
affordable trains and that invests in
innovative green ways to move around a
Europe in which the young adults of
tomorrow have clean lungs clear minds
and are independent of powerful lobbies
we want to Europe with the powers to
investigate crimes that transcends the
borders of the Member States for example
terrorism and cybercrime a European
autonomous independent agency that is
empowered to investigate these crimes in
the EU we want to Europe with a common
European television channel available in
several languages which showcases
European TV series this will bridge
language barriers and increase knowledge
about our European neighbors whilst also
promoting a European identity
we want a Europe that makes better use
of Education and employment
opportunities as integration tools
refugees should be given the right to
work immediately so that they do not
have to depend on government support
they should also have access to EU
funded obligatory language classes we
want a Europe that invests in
sustainable youth employment that
addresses the skills gap and abettor
recognizes creativity the soft skills
and practical know-how unregulated
unpaid internships for post graduates
where there is no chance of being hired
after completion are not acceptable
you